- He's an American boxer widely
regarded as the best fighter
of his generation and listed as one
of the greatest boxers of all time.
He's undefeated as a professional boxer
and has won 12 world titles.
Forbes magazine listed him as
the highest paid athlete in the world.
He's Floyd Mayweather
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
- The only thing we could
is take one day at a time.
You know, it's all we can do.
No one is perfect.
Every day we strive to be perfectionist,
but no one is perfect.
I make mistakes.
You know, I've said things
that I shouldn't have said.
When I was younger, I done
things that I shouldn't
have done when I was younger.
I'm not perfect.
But we live and we learn and
that's a part of growing.
- [MC] Mayweather, with a right
over the top, stones Manfredy.
Manfredy in trouble.
As Mayweather pounds away,
Manfredy almost went down.
He won't take a knee, but
he isn't throwing back.
Mayweather pounding, pounding
and this one's going to be stopped.
And Floyd Mayweather, Jr. has
another big stunning victory
to cap off his rise to stardom.
- Jealousy.
People jealous of you
'cause we're success.
So, any time you're successful,
people going to be jealous of you.
People not always going to like you.
Sometime when you in class,
some people don't like you
when you in school, right?
But that don't stop you from going, right?
And you still go there
and be your best, right?
So, same thing like my job.
I still go there and be at my best.
- [MC] Right hand is solid.
Combinations by Mayweather.
Too much speed.
Maybe too much power too.
There's a vicious right hand over the top.
He promised he would
humiliate Arturo Gatti
before his fans.
It's getting brutal in there
as Mayweather fires at will.
- [Announcer] Mayweather
captured the title
with a technical knockout
in the sixth round.
- I mean I think it was a
I just had a game plan.
I had a brilliant game plan.
The game plan was to be
very outspoken, you know.
I was born with personality.
I was born with charisma.
Speak my mind.
Speak from the heart.
You know, I don't hate or dislike anyone,
but I wanted to go out
there, you know, and just
do what I have to do
inside that square circle,
choose a tremendous team on the outside
that's going to help me take
things to the next level
and that's what I did.
- [MC] Good quick left
hook inside by Mayweather
and a big right hand upstairs by Floyd.
Biggest shot of the night for Mayweather
and Mayweather is trying
to knock Oscar out
with a right hand.
Mayweather beginning to
operate like a surgeon.
Fighting Floyd Mayweather
is a dose of cold reality.
And where does Mayweather
go from this pinnacle
after claiming that he's going to retire?
They fight to the finish
and please the crowd.
To the dismay of the almost unanimously
pro-De La Hoyan crowd,
Mayweather was awarded the
split-decision victory.
- You got fighters
that may be faster than me.
You got fighters that
may hit harder than me.
You got fighters that's very athletic.
But you don't have no fighter
than can make adjustments like me.
You don't have fighters that
can be on my level mentally.
It's never personal for me.
It's always business.
Every other fighter
fight for certain things.
Everybody fight for what they fight for.
My thing is this.
I keep my eyes on the prize.
I never focus on things outside the ring.
My focus is the guy that's in front of me.
You get to where you're trying to get to
by staying focused,
staying on a parallel path.
I always had a dream,
and my dream was to be the best.
No matter what happens Saturday.
When it comes down to boxing,
I'm the best at this.
- [MC] Good quick left hook by
Mayweather as Hatton came in.
Sometimes it's the right hand,
sometimes it's the left hook.
Huge round for Mayweather
here in the eighth.
Mayweather believes he's
got Hatton in big trouble.
Hatton continued to come forward
and allowed Mayweather to
close in emphatic fashion.
- [MC] What a left hook.
What a perfect shot.
(crowd cheering)
This fight is over.
Floyd Mayweather has a knockout victory.
- I feel if I work hard, I can play hard.
This is me.
Didn't nobody get in there
and put the gloves on for me.
Didn't nobody go out there on that road
and run miles and miles for me.
Nobody took the broken ribs.
Nobody took the bloody nose.
I did it all.
I dedicated myself to my
craft and I bust my ass.
I'm going to continue to
keep believing in my skills,
keep listening to my father,
keep listening to my uncle,
and sit on this throne for 30 months.
- [MC] Round by round, it became clear
that smaller Marquez could not deal
with the speed and power
of Mayweather's punches.
And he is quantity Juan
Manuel Marquez in this round.
Brilliant combination by Mayweather.
If that didn't hurt Marquez,
I'm not sure what would.
This is the kind of performance
that will convince many
that Floyd is still the
best fighter in the world.
What a return to the sport.
Twenty-one months old and
he's better than ever.
In dominant fashion, Mayweather rolled
to the unanimous decision victory.
- To become great, you
have to follow greatness.
But to become a great leader,
you have to be a great follower.
To be successful, you got
to want to follow success.
And I want every fighter
to just stay focused,
stay on the parallel path.
- [MC] But from round three onward,
Mayweather got into his
rhythm controlling the pace,
attacking with precision.
- [MC] That was a stunning
shot from Mayweather
right on the button.
Another stunning right hand by Mayweather
and a big left hook.
He's landing shots cleanly inside.
Floyd is very much more
compact and more powerful.
With each passing round,
Mayweather's advantages
and quickness in timing
became more pronounced.
Shane can't handle the speed
and the coordination of Mayweather.
It's that simple.
Floyd Mayweather's skill level,
Floyd Mayweather's conditioning,
Floyd Mayweather's
application to the sport
is, at this moment, unique
and he stands alone.
- Nineteen years, and I
reflect back over my career.
I can't just say I'm going out 49 and 0.
You can never overlook anyone.
In this camp did I push myself?
Absolutely.
Every fight played a major key.
All 48 fights played a major key.
It's not just the intelligence.
It's the sharp mind.
It's the good chin.
It's the tremendous heart.
I never overlooked no opponent.
I trained for every fighter the same way.
I pushed myself.
I believe in my skills and
I believe in my talent.
(crowd cheering)
- [MC] Protect yourself at all times.
It was legal.
It was legal and it's officially a KO.
Ortiz is apologizing and
Mayweather was punching.
We can all say he was exciting in the ring
as he has been outside the ring.
- There's no blueprint on how to beat me.
I can crack any Da Vinci
code when I'm in that ring.
I'm the best.
- [Stephen A. Smith]
Right now, do you believe
you're the best in the world?
- I feel I'm the best ever.
I broke everybody record.
Tell me who record I haven't broke?
It's not bragging or boasting.
The proof is in the pudding.
Men lie, women lie.
Numbers don't lie.
- Doesn't matter who it is.
Doesn't matter if it's Sugar Ray Leonard,
Sugar Ray Robinson, Muhammad
Ali, it doesn't matter.
- I respect them.
I take my hat off to them,
but you think I gave
this sport my whole life
to say there's another
fighter that's better than me?
Absolutely not.
- [MC] The good part is
in due with the punches.
So he can get back in
the fight with one punch.
That's it.
- [MC] I don't think Floyd's worried
about his punches any more.
That's it.
Looks like three of four
straight right hands.
Rick Duran is going to throw in the towel.
Rick Duran is showing Endo the towel
and Endo saying, "No, don't throw it in."
Endo is shaking his head at Duran saying,
"No, no, don't throw the towel in."
And now the referee does it for him.
- I want to thank my team
because without my team,
all this wouldn't be possible.
It's been a long road.
It's been a long journey,
but, you know, hard work
and dedication paid off.
It's always been one of my dreams
to come back to the motherland.
And I'm here now.
It took 36 years, but I'm here
and I want to thank all
you guys for the support.
I mean, every time I
go our there and fight,
I just don't represent
the red, white and blue.
Floyd Mayweather represents the world.
And I had a lot of
support and, once again,
I didn't do it by myself.
I had a tremendous team
and a lot of people supporting me.
And for all those that flew
over to Las Vegas to see me
or wherever I was fighting
at, I'm very, very thankful
for everybody that bought Pay-Per-View
and for my team, working with
guys to get me over here.
It's truly a dream come true.
- [MC] Bobby Giepert as Mayweather looks
for another opportunity
to land a right hand.
Bangs a left to the body.
Giepert now fiddling with the nose
as he tries to get the blood flow to stop.
And Mayweather comes back with
rights, and Giepert goes down
and Joe Cortez says, "That'll do."
One minute, 28 seconds of the first round,
or about a minute and a
half of the first round,
something like that, and Floyd Mayweather
has yet another quick KO victory.
- Some guy's game plan,
we going to rush him.
We're going to rush him. Okay.
What's your second game plan?
That's plan A. What's plan B?
Pack, yo, he can set the
trap for other fighters,
but you can't set the
trap for Floyd Mayweather.
Because you've got to have
plan A, you have to plan B,
and if you don't have a
plan B, you go to plan C.
I've never beat a fighter with my A game.
- [MC] He's got shaky legs.
He's got to buy time here.
He's not the type of fighter
who knows how to do that.
Every situation for Hatton
This fight is over.
Floyd Mayweather has a knockout
victory over Ricky Hatton.
- [MC] Mayweather dealt
with a situation he's never,
or a fighter who he's never
been confronted with before.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Anton Turner asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Floyd Mayweather's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you.
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.